foreign
he says I'm 45 years old I'm married
with two children under 12 and
completely debt free I took a new job a
year and a half ago making 100K a year
and my wife is a stay-at-home mom the
nature of my job requires me to be on
call and close to work leaving me little
choice but to pay a premium rent of 2
000 per month we are currently watching
the housing market and still learning
the area and are socking money away to
buy a home I have 45 000 in the bank
doing nothing for me but I've been
hesitant to invest as we would like to
have the money available should a home
come up that we can buy I've been told
that cash and Savings in a savings
account is like melting ice what do I do
with it hmm well in this situation you
know when it comes to saving uh for a
house it's a little bit different than
just you know any other money that
you're putting aside you know typically
we wouldn't invest uh the money that
you're saving for a house unless you
know the timeline is you know five years
or more although Dave I've heard you say
that a lot of times you'll just pop some
money in an index fund and let it sit
there and grow if you
you know know what you might use it for
I particularly don't have this stomach
for that I'd probably put it in hysa and
just get the best return on it that I
possibly could for the time being
because it sounds like you're kind of in
that moment where if the right thing
comes open you're ready to jump on it so
yeah I would keep it out of the market
and I would put it in a high yield
savings account maybe put it you know
I've heard Dave say that he'll put it in
a CD that sort of thing yeah high yield
savings account like you said it's
perfect
um it's not melting ice
when you are getting ready to use the
money
and you're getting ready to use this
money and so if you're going to leave it
in a stupid savings account for 10 years
then yeah it is melting ice yeah but
that's not your description you're in
the housing market you're ready to buy
and get rid of this premium rent and
everything else so yeah you definitely
go that route it's you're not doing the
wrong thing no Jade I did have a young
guy come in uh all the work I've done
over the years with different NFL and
and other professional athletes
um they just happen to be listening to
the show and say hey would you look at
my stuff yeah look at your stuff so it's
always interesting stories and of course
we've run into all the negative stories
where they've burned through all the
money you know I'll make 100 million
dollars I got nothing to show for it or
whatever that kind of stuff I've met
those guys and there's always a lot of
Shame and stuff on those guys but in the
in the in the light of what Ryan is
saying
this guy comes in he's young I mean he's
like 20. oh well 28 years old maybe 26
years old he'd been he been the league a
few years but not you know he wasn't an
old guy in the league by any stretch and
his sweet little wife and
uh they they drive in a used van
wow and they come in and they go like
Dave you're going to kill us we've
messed up and I'm thinking they're going
to tell me they've blown all their money
and he goes I I you're just gonna be so
mad at me and I'm like number one I'm
not gonna be mad at you we're going to
just how dumb you are but what did you
do I mean did you do something dumb and
he goes yeah we've got all our money in
savings account
and I said uh how much money do you have
in savings account uh 36 million oh oh
whoa
and I'm like no I am not going to yell
at you I'm going to hug you because you
did everything right but one tiny thing
you actually you're a pro athlete who
has money you know what this is a
unicorn I mean you're incredible way to
go you're amazing I'm so proud of you
you actually lived on less than you make
you're driving a used car you're not
trying to impress your Posse you know
you're you're out you didn't buy your
mother a house you couldn't afford to
buy all the stupid butt stuff I usually
run into you have 36 million dollars and
the only thing you did wrong was you
didn't invest it no you you get a hug
you know so but yeah in his case he is
melting ice for sure he does need to get
that money invested so he was wrong but
not only get yelled at wrong side though
the smart side way to go man I mean wow
absolute stud